the burgers nowadays mean not being able
to contact to at least one person in
your family this is what it means to
almost all eager families around the
world everyone at least have one to ten
family members or a locked up in
concentration camp or disappeared ill
ham to tea is one of those jailed we
Gers he was a prominent voice in the
Muslim community until his arrest in
2013 he was detained when leaving for
the US with his then 18 year old
daughter
Juha since 2017 I have not heard about
my father I don't know if he's safe I
don't know if he's still in the same
prison if he's even alive the Chinese
government accuses Totti of being a
separatist and an extremist publicly
calling him a terrorist in 2014 he was
sentenced to life in prison by a Chinese
Court
my father is nothing close to an
extremist
my father is nothing nothing close to
someone who was advocating for violence
but only whether my father out forever
used is his pen and his words Tang Bao
is a human rights activist and a friend
of Totti he is influential among wiggers
and his the one of the most important
people raising hands handles people and
bigger people he is telling the world
the wiggers
have human rights the leaders are not
calling for terrorism or separatism Tang
has known Totti since 2009 a year marked
by bloody ethnic conflict in the wigger
region of Xinjiang in northwestern China
when the Muslim minority revolted
against police brutality the protests
were violently put down currently
there are at least 2 million acres and
Kazakhs and other Muslims detained in
concentration camps they were
brainwashed and tortured and the
children and family were separated some
women have been raped what's happening
in Sinjar the East Turkestan is the
biggest of humanity humanitarian
disaster in 21st century
according to international rights
organizations the Chinese government has
been silently building internment camps
across the region
and unlawfully jailing Regas officially
to protect the country against
separatism and terrorism Beijing
initially denied the existence of
internment camps but now describes them
as vocational training schools to fight
terrorism basic right of the Weaver
include the political cultural economic
religious alright has been continued
while it is by this Chinese Communist
Party s Turkestan and a so called
shinjang originalist
like open air presence and the Chinese
government today trying to eradicate it
we will identity completely the euro the
new suit have clear message to Chinese
government this kind of concentration
camps that torture the disappearance
that actually a traditional killings are
not accepted in September the European
Parliament awarded l-hamd ot with the
2019 Sakharov Prize for freedom of
thought
[Music]
the first step is to tell the truth to
tell the world was happening in Jinja
tell the world who is Elohim party and
what he has been doing so to give him a
wart is a good thing across the world
people are rising up to condemn China's
actions against the weaker community I
wish my father can be released I wish he
can be safe I wish all the other
families just like me and my family they
can be reunited one day their family
members can be safe and healthy and
alive and I wish people just can live in
peace without hurting each other
[Music]